i'm annie onishi and i am a trauma
surgeon and surgical critical care
doctor in los angeles california
and today is thursday march 19th hello
again it's may 19
2020. for the past 10 weeks i've been
chronicling what my life has been like
during the copa 19 pandemic live from
my apartment good morning it is
wednesday
march 18th thursday may 14th
it's been really busy a week's worth of
night shifts made myself a nice stiff
drink
this is my story
as of today at 12 p.m there's
in los angeles county 231 cases to
deaths
good morning it is wednesday march 18th
it's about 5 45 or 5 50 in the morning
i'm
walking into work right now i feel
like when you're a kid at the beach and
you see a big wave coming and you know
it's going to knock you down and there's
really nothing you can do about it
everyone's sort of waiting for the
onslaught that's coming in the next
couple of weeks
once the medical icu has reached their
capacity of 50 patients then they're
going to start to get admitted to
my unit the trauma and surgical icu so
we're getting ready for it
everybody's a little nervous everybody's
a little quiet the place is empty
happy wednesday everyone i take the five
to work which is i guess one of the
busiest freeways in america and
there's no traffic so that is all the
information that you need
so the n95s are hard to come by we are
being asked to reuse them five
times before we dispose of them if you
take it off you touch
viral particles it gets soaking wet in
there it's disgusting to ask us to reuse
it is like
insane recently one educational effort
that came through my icu was
the medical icu nurses teaching these
surgical icu nurses how to what's called
prone
a patient when a patient needs to be
prone we order a special bed from a
special company that straps them down
and rotates them and they just lie
face down so we are learning how to
manually prune the patients so flip them
ourselves and keep them flipped
we in this field are pretty much
all assuming that we will all get
covid19 we will all at some point be
infectious if we're not already so
believe it or not we
are actually running what's called a
skeleton crew there are actually fewer
doctors and residents and fellows and
staff in the hospital than there
normally would be
so that when the rise and crest of this
pandemic does hit our hospital we'll
have people who
are home and well and healthy and ready
to go
it is friday march 20th it's 5 50 in the
morning
getting ready to go to work today is my
first trauma call
since the shelter and place order in los
angeles started and since
all these crazy measures and and since
the outbreak really hit los angeles
so usually you know in my day-to-day
life i'm an icu doctor but today i have
my trauma surgery hat on
so uh we'll see how things are different
today from a from a
trauma perspective let you guys know
i hope that i have continued to stay
positive and keep my head up
all right it's just scary
you just have to um you just have to go
to work every day and you have to
wash your hands and and do your best and
listen for the plans and and and speak
up if you see something that's fixable
and and just
you know take care of the patients today
on trauma call
it has been q u
i e d which is a word we don't usually
use around here one thing i hadn't
thought about until the last couple days
is what happens if my hospital is full
of coveted patients
and i don't have an icu bed or an
operating room
or space or resources for a trauma
patient that comes in
you know stretching the system means it
affects everybody whether you have
covert or not
and that's not really something i hadn't
thought about until today on trauma call
i will talk to you guys next time bye
good morning it is i don't even know
what day it is
it's the 24th of march i just wrapped up
a 24-hour shift
we were really busy with non-covered
patients so
again it was like another normal kind of
regular day for me
i've noticed i am starting to have
something that feels a little bit like
survivor's guilt
when i hear from my friends back in new
york who
are working at hospitals where they're
out of ventilators and
they're starting to turn operating rooms
into icu pods
and i feel bad because i'm not
like directly helping with the covid
patients and
and with this national or worldwide
crisis
and i i still have other patients to
help so try to focus on helping them and
try to stay positive and
wash my hands and stay home when i'm not
at work that's about
where we are today remember when i was
complaining about not being busy
it's one o'clock in the morning and
we've been operating non-stop
on gunshot wounds go figure
hey everyone it is friday march 27th
it is my quarantine day my day home and
away from the hospital
i have applied for emergency privileges
back at a large hospital system in new
york so that in the event that
um things don't get super busy here in
la i can go back and help
be it mop the floors or
adjust ventilator settings who knows but
yeah that's where we are today just
still watching and waiting and
you know who knows what's going to come
in la if obviously my first priority is
my patients and my colleagues here but
if it gets to the point where it's clear
that more help is needed elsewhere then
i'm ready to do that
um that's where we're at today it is
saturday march 28th and i'm on trauma
call we did one gallbladder this morning
um i've had a couple of non-urgent
trauma consults it's been pretty slow
again
and it feels really frustrating and it
feels um terrible
to have a skill set and know i could
help but um but i'm not physically there
right now and we
why can't we organize a better way to to
get resources where they're needed when
they're needed
so that's what's on my mind today just
waiting waiting waiting
it is thursday april 2nd and
it's been really busy and i realized i
hadn't made a little entry
in a few days so i thought i would take
a few minutes and give you guys an
update about
what's been happening there are a fair
number of intubated patients with
covalent in my hospital now
you know they're taking up all the
negative pressure rooms first and then
sort of spreading from there
i will say the first time i walked past
a patient who i knew had covered in my
icu it felt pretty surreal because this
is something we've been preparing for
and worrying about and
waiting for and then finally one day
here was a regular person
who was minding their own business and
got this horrible disease and now
they're here in our unit
the wave is here it's it's starting up
it's still been exhausting it feels like
we've been doing this for years but it's
only been a couple of weeks and it
hasn't even really hit us yet a couple
things that have changed
uh i sit here now our little call room
this is like normally just where we
sleep on call it's kind of like just
this depressing bed
normally i would sit in our trauma
office but i'm trying to socially
distance so i
sit in here all day and hide that's
about it it's
friday april 3rd it's about 1 pm in the
afternoon
today at my hospital the medical icu is
completely full we got
our first patient who's coepositive who
i am now primarily responsible for i'm
the main doctor for
the covid patient it was a pleasure to
meet this man he is
a nice man middle-aged otherwise
completely normal completely healthy but
just got sick about a week ago and
couldn't breathe and came to the
emergency room and his oxygen levels
were really really low
right now he's on a little bit of extra
oxygen therapy but his
breathing rate is very fast so it makes
us worried that he's
may at some point need a breathing tube
so that's why he's here in the intensive
care unit probably
more where that's coming from so from
now on the code patients who come in
through the ed
who need icu care are gonna come to my
unit so that's where we are
this particular patient came to the er
with a week of
symptoms of shortness of breath actually
he had a lot of gi
complaints so diarrhea nausea vomiting
taking care of this guy is definitely
different than taking care of my other
typical trauma or surgical icu patients
who need stuff
done to them this guy just needs
supportive care and monitoring close
monitoring
it is april 8th wednesday a week's worth
of night shift so i got my schedule
pretty well flipped at this point
leading that nocturnal life trauma has
been steadily busy i've had a couple of
big trauma cases this week including a
young man who got shot directly in the
heart who saved him so that was a pretty
good case and mickey's still been full
so we've also been emitting covetation
so that's also been steady tonight the
big to do will be
right around 10 pm we'll have to flip
the patients onto their stomachs
so they spent a few hours this afternoon
on their backs getting all the nursing
care but they spend most of the night
and most of the day on their stomachs so
i have to sort of help out with that
it's very labor intensive it involves
about six or seven people
and that's it it is friday april 10th
and i'm about to go in for the night
shift but i wanted to introduce everyone
to my new orchid
tony named obviously for dr anthony
fauci
a man of science and a hero for our time
and tony was a gift from a very generous
local florist who brought
this morning's brought pallets and
pallets and pallets of the most
beautiful orchids you ever saw
and they were giving them out to the
nurses and doctors on the night shift
leaving the hospital this morning was
amazing
we know that these small businesses are
hurting right now they have to be
and the people who own these businesses
are taking time out of their day and
money out of their budgets and who even
knows where they're getting this money
to try to help us and cheer us up and
keep us positive
and it's really amazing and it's an
honor and a privilege to take care of
patients and
this is we're just doing our jobs that's
how i feel at least i'm just doing my
job
so all the generosity that's been shown
really feels above and beyond
and um i really appreciate it first of
all and i know
uh i hope tony has a nice life here
we'll see
[Music]
good morning it's friday april 17th and
i just
took my mask down just for a minute to
say good morning and hello and
heading into the hospital for
a week in the icu and um i've heard it's
been pretty busy and pretty crazy
so much so that our trauma center was
actually on diversion yesterday which
means that
ambulances and the firefighters were not
bringing traumas to our hospital because
our units were so full so that's a big
difference from
when i last rounded a week ago so we'll
see how the day goes
yeah that's it talk to you guys soon
it is april 20th and today is a really
awesome and really good day and i'm
super happy a couple hours ago we
extubated which means
remove the breeding tube out from my
first covey patient which
i'm just looking at the chart now he was
admitted to my icu on april 3rd he's had
the breathing tube in for
like almost that entire time and today
we took out the reading tube and he
looks amazing he looks
like a million bucks so could not be
happier feels like a really big win
um we've had a rough couple of days with
a bunch of really sick patients and
some covid patients taking good steps
forward and some uh
just not making any progress whatsoever
and that is
incredibly frustrating as a as a doctor
but he looks great and i'll take this
big one and uh
the first thing he asked for was a
tamarindo jarito
a type of soda that's very popular
around here so
if you guys told him if he does well and
he continues to breathe nicely that i'll
bring him on
maybe a little later tonight or tomorrow
so big win
the three p's in taking care of these
folks is
uh proning paralysis and patience
because you want to fix the numbers and
you want the patient to get better but
sometimes it just takes a long time and
that's just really different from
trauma and surgical critical care
another code
patient of mine is doing very very badly
and
pretty much failing every therapy that
we
have he has by definition ards the
acute respiratory distress syndrome we
have him paralyzed to relax all his
muscles so the machine can breathe more
efficiently for him
and we have him prone which means he's
lying on on his stomach
and he's not doing well his oxygen
levels are extremely low and
there's blood coming out of his
endotracheal tube and
we consulted some of the cardiothoracic
surgeons at our hospital for
consideration for ecmotherapy
ecmotherapy is a machine that
basically replaces the work of your
either your lungs or your heart and your
lungs
it's pretty much a last resort so the
guy's not doing well
it has been an absolute whirlwind and a
real learning experience and
pretty exhausting we're thinking about
this patient tonight and hopefully he's
doing better in the morning but we'll
see
[Music]
i've been reasonably busy there are a
couple of different national
groups and bodies keeping track of how
individual hospitals are
doing taking care of the cove patients
and so i got roped into being the person
who goes through the charts
and types in the lab values and the age
and the birthday and the
which medications were given on this day
um so i'm i'm doing that
it is taking forever it takes probably
about an hour per patient
you know it could be worse i should be
grateful that
um you know the the pandemic hasn't
struck my city of los
angeles so badly that i am able to stay
home and do data entry
as opposed to being working you know 24
7 in a crowded icu so
i guess that's the silver lining and
probably do
another couple hours of data entry and
then uh head back to the netflix
coming to you live from my apartment you
know i remember
back in march i i sort of made the
analogy of like
a wave that's coming and that was
probably true
in a place like new york but here it's
less of a wave more of like a slowly
rising flood
you just kind of stand here watching the
numbers creep up and up and up
the medical ic was full surgical icu is
busy and we still have a handful maybe
five or six
um covered patients it's been this whole
time it's been 15.
but that's just going to go up as social
distancing restrictions are lifting
um which you know i i want
the economy to get going and i want
people to have their jobs and i
i want to make moves forward but
it's hard to justify that when i know
that the testing
in order to make this happen is not
there the contact tracing in order to
make this safe is not there
it's a shitty situation and uh i'm
feeling it and i'm looking forward to
get back on service on monday
um so this weekend probably just some
more uh reading relaxing let me go for a
run early in the morning with my face
covering
and just trying to stay positive
[Music]
today was my second day back on service
in the surgical icu
um i am tired already after two days on
service which is not
good for me i usually have a lot more
stamina than that but
just been running around like a damn
headless chicken taking care of all
these coveted patients they're
really um they're very i'm
they're they're high maintenance um the
critically ill covered patients need a
lot of uh
tinkering lots of little adjustments
here and there
and then checking to see whether your
intervention had a good effect or not so
our census right now is about 19
patients or 20 patients something like
that
um half of whom are half coveted
and of those patients about half of them
are intubated
of those intubated patients uh two or
three of them
are i would classify as critically
critically ill all the therapies that
we're doing with the ventilator and all
the medications are
now working and their
lungs are just impossible to to
ventilate
and uh their oxygen levels are insanely
low and
slowly but surely other organ systems
start to fail so their heart starts to
fail their kidneys start to fail
and it's uh it is like an impossible
spiral it's really frustrating
the rest of our unit is sort of um sort
of normal for us just your typical
car crashes stab wounds gunshots
just a year ago i thought that stuff was
really hard and it took all my mental
energy but now these days these
trauma patients are like super easy
been a crazy couple of days um hopefully
things settle in
a little bit this week i have some good
help from all my colleagues and my
co-workers and my co-fellows
so yeah just hanging in there today is
thursday may 14th
it's five in the afternoon it has been a
really hard
couple of days we've had a couple of our
copic patients get really sick
and a couple trauma patients just be
really really sick also and then
everybody's been working really hard to
take care of um
you know like the three or four super
super sick people in the unit
and then today um three of them died
it is just it just sucks and morales you
can just
i feel really bad for my nurses you just
walk in and
the body language is very defeated and
it's quiet and
um we help a lot of patients and um
there's just some that we can't help and
it's really it is very frustrating
it's been tough and how can life go on
when everything like that is still
happening here
that's today uh just taking a little
break getting a little peace and quiet
and
uh have a few other things to check up
on but just needed a minute before we
get back out there doing god's work
you know hello again
it's may 19 2020. tony the orchid is
looking amazing
he's starting to drop the flowers which
i'm told is a natural part of the
process
and most importantly these are very
thick green roots so that's how you can
really judge the
um health of an orchid plant is by the
roots
i will be forever grateful that this
happened in
a certain way because i think that the
silver lining of this is it's going to
help me take care of patients going
forward believe it or not
today is thursday may 21st it's 6 30 p.m
and i'm just waking up and having my
coffee it has been
insanely busy this week trauma-wise at
night
bonkers a couple nights ago um we had
probably six or seven people all stabbed
in separate unrelated incidents
had a guy like he was like on drugs or
something stabbed himself all over his
body he got himself in the crowded got
both eyeballs that guy was really messed
up
we had um two patients come in
in full cardiac arrest one from a
gunshot wound to the chest
one from a stab wound to the chest and
then not even an hour afterwards we had
a lady
come in who was apparently minding her
own business and got
shot and it took out one of her iliac
arteries so we were operating on her
operate all night long and then you go
check on the the patients in the icu and
you have your little
quiet covet corner pocket and i think
that that's just going to be
the new normal here as society starts to
reopen
i think that's just what we're going to
have to get used to in the hospital is
just
this new level of unpredictability
paired with
just the the long slow burn of always
having a few of these patients around
and
you know i think we're just gonna have
to roll the punches and and get used to
it and uh
yeah that's gonna be about it i think
party on
i think for the foreseeable future our
hospital will continue to treat and
manage these patients
uh in my icu the average time of a that
a cova patient spends on a ventilator is
something like 19 or 20 days
as you can see in this image the
hospital has taken steps to
convert certain pods of the icu
into completely negative pressure areas
it's hard to communicate with the nurse
when you're in there
and um so you end up shouting the hepa
filters are really loud
so that's hard you know you're knocking
on the door and waving to get somebody
to bring something to you
we use a lot of white boards to write
things down to ask for stuff or
or communicate with each other i think
the most surprising thing about the
patients
has been sometimes less is more when
you're a surgical intensivist
you really want to try to fix every
little number
but these patients are so sick and so
delicate that you you can't and you will
sacrifice
other parts of their physiology to fix
different parts of their physiology so
you can't make their labs look perfect
you can't make their numbers look
perfect on the ventilator so you have to
just settle for good enough
and just go from there and take it day
by day i really miss restaurants
i love eating and i love going out to
eat and trying new places
i miss my husband i haven't seen him in
a while
the day-to-day surgical icu thing that i
miss is like
popping in and out of rooms to fuss with
stuff and fix stuff and talk to the
patient
and we don't do that anymore like even
our non-coveted patients like i just
it's there's just something that changed
and it doesn't feel right to pop into
and out of a patient's room anymore
i feel like a little bit like a typhoid
mary because i have these known
exposures so i
i feel bad like seeing other people
[Music]
really tough death today one of our code
players who'd been in the unit for
a month to the day today and it just
sucks
i got home and then on the news it was
announced that today
we reached a hundred thousand death
mark in america and that's just like i
mean that's insane if you think about
like if that is insane
how shitty i feel right now and how she
that family feels and how sad they were
i mean
his wife was just like she
crumpled that's a hundred thousand of
those right in the last three months
it's an incomprehensible number
everything's opening back up how can we
be moving on how can these this be over
this is it doesn't feel over
uh in the icu and there's nothing really
else to say or do
hug your people and tell your people you
love them and
you know just try to pick yourself up
and dust yourself off and get back to
work tomorrow
i will talk to you guys next time that's
where we're at today that's about it
that's it talk to you guys soon that's
gonna be about it i think
party on